hey there hi I'm Jacob and uh from
Sacramento sup Jacob and I was wondering
that if when you were a kid you knew
that you were going to grow up to play a
superhero which you would have wanted to
be and why so if you ate when you were
growing up which superhero would you
wanted to play Batman
I'm definitely Batman I had Superman
pajamas
starring every one of my Batman yeah so
I wanna play spider-man I think it's
about time we had a female spider-man I
don't woman I wanted to be like lion-o
from the Thundercats
that would be Superman was right several
several pajamas
you still got the pajama my mom just
found a Superman the onesie of one that
which I don't fit anymore hmm
great question being a girl
Captain America let's do our
oh you know yes I just want to know I
just wanted to grow up I was so grateful
the light and I wanted to be an actor
and I had no idea that I would be
sitting here today talking to you about
this very subject but I'm I I never
really had a desire to be a superhero
I'm just delighted that I can be a part
of it and and and I never thought at
this that I would be at this age which
is advanced merging this one I'm
becoming firestorm I'm thrilled to be
doing it
great next question hi I'm Morgan from
Orange County in my question is if you
could be any superhero other than who
you play who would you be big bazoo man
I'd be the gr from Dragon Ball Z yeah
the Saiyan Prince
I think I'd like to be the atom because
I'd like to get very small and be able
to sneak around you could put on the
suit
dr. Q I don't want to put on this enough
to see you in to see that be amazing
down there um I want to be vixen wanna
channel animals seems like a really cool
power I crossing over but I guess
Captain America is there a superhero
with really long like really stretchy
arms yeah yeah miss laughs I'm a
delegate man miss Reed rings yeah ah
nice just go it's sitting with reach
things this mr. Phang
it's the only room we have heckled
superhero names appear does that mean
she thinks you are mister felt ass I
think I'm taking it okay
I didn't Catwoman cattle Moo be ready
fun I already gave my like I'll take
suggestions from anybody just tweet me
and all that's my answer
Wonder Woman
John you keep putting that out in the
world it's gonna it's going to happen I
feel like it's gonna happen sooner
rather than later it's just like we're
saying earlier it's good to see strong
female characters that's awesome
hi I'm Christina from Monterrey Mexico
big fan so last season you announced the
Justice Society and my question is about
Hawkman because he's a very important
member of this team so are you going to
further develop his character or are you
going to focus on new characters I think
you know we're really excited about our
new characters and we're bringing the
JSA that's it you know we've always said
to both Falcon Sierra that we haven't
finished telling the story of the Hawks
yet so and I was just emailing with both
of them earlier this week so anything is
possible and when we you know have at
the right time with the right story we
would love to you know continue to see
Kendra and Carter I feel like they're in
the Bahamas right now life is lounging
on the beach in a nest
all right yep dating each other worms
coming to help
hi I'm ruined from the Bahamas yeah so
hello shirt bro good shirt thank you
thank you
idea my question goes to all of you on
the panel which is what era of time
would you like to live in you know past
present future I would like to live in
like medieval times like I have a thing
Huggies weird thing about like medieval
stuff lack on horseback like jousting
I'd want to be like a knight I could be
like the Black Knight you're just like
super dope I could see myself on
horseback swinging like an axe or some
craziness yeah that's kind of my thing I
can see that too yeah similar for me
although I'd rather maybe a big king we
could fight if I wanted to but then I
you know get the best room in the house
just have to one-up me I think I want to
live in that I'm obsessed with like sit
in the 60s in the music scene of the 60
s and living like 60s London and wear
really nice trousers
I look good in the sixties I basically
want the girl I'd seen the pictures
I like to I'd like to I think although
actually I'm quite happy to be here now
I like this like I like this time
although it's terrifying but I'm curious
around all okay but uh I think I'll go I
think I'd look good in the 20s it's all
about how I'd look yeah so I think the
20s could be it would be a kind of cool
time to be I know what else in a dream
I'd like to be in the 1940s the the kind
of the surge of the MGM musicals and try
to be a part of that I think that would
be awesome
you